[Music]
all right less than a month ago a
massive category 4 hurricane made
landfall on the Gulf Coast of Florida in
the Panhandle 35 counties were under a
state of emergency
155 mile-per-hour winds
wreaking havoc throughout the Panhandle
the destruction as you can see as we saw
was horrific entire blocks were
literally wiped away the area sustained
billions upon billions of dollars in
damage but on November the 6th
Floridians in the Panhandle they went to
the polls and their votes were counted
every single one of them on time in
accordance with Florida law and
Florida's Constitution sadly the same
cannot be said in southern Florida in
Palm Beach Broward counties we are
witnessing a colossal disaster laws have
been broken Florida's Constitution
ignored none of this was caused by a
hurricane but rather by local officials
who are incompetent corrupt and
obviously feel they are above the law
that 65 other Florida counties 65 or 67
adhered to in Palm Beach County at least
15,000 new ballots were unearthed and
counted after election night and in
Broward County almost 75,000 so-called
uncounted votes magically turning up day
after day after day after the election
tens of thousands of lost ballots just
seemingly appeared out of thin air the
vast majority of course cast by
Democrats now this should not let me be
straightforward this should not be
Republican Democrat conservative liberal
this is this shouldn't be about politics
this is much deeper whatever your
political affiliation what we're
witnessing is a horrific miscarriage of
America's most fundamental rights and a
serious potential now criminal violation
the law is clear it is unambiguous
Florida law was put it on the screen
quote says the canvassing board shall
report all early voting all tabulated
vote-by-mail results to the Department
of State within 30
it's after the polls close the law
continues quote the canvassing board
shall report with the exception of
provisional ballot results updated
precinct election results to the
department at least every 45 minutes
until results are completely reported 65
a Florida 67 counties they complied with
the law including every county in the
Panhandle that was absolutely ravaged by
Hurricane Michael 27 days prior to the
election Broward Palm Beach counties
totally ignored the law broke the law
for days Broward County officials
continued to tally literally tens of
thousands of votes in violation of state
law
it appears yet again we have one system
of justice and elections for Democrats
and another for the rest of us now the
Supervisor of Elections in Broward
County woman by the name of Brenda
Snipes would not even tell state
officials where these mysterious votes
were coming from where the votes had
been how many votes were left to be
counted again a violation of law there
was no updating of votes every 45
minutes again violating the law and this
morning multiple boxes full of sample
and provisional ballots left behind in
some rental car were actually discovered
by an Avis employee at Fort Lauderdale
Airport this is in sanity you know we
send election observers to other
countries we need them here and on
Friday
Florida congressman Matt gates literally
blocked from observing a location where
ballots were being loaded into a truck
take a look for yourself why can't we
watch what's going on man so it can't be
here who told you that we can't watch
what's going on out of the truck who's
your super yeah I would love to see me
until then will you tell me why we can't
know what's going in and out of that
truck and who what's the name your
supervisor
do you know isn't do you know who's her
name the supervisors name
yeah what's their name bring Mathewson
do you know their name what is it we
tell to me brew music what we're seeing
in South Florida is a national disgrace
and it's far worse than that Broward
Palm Beach counties violated any chance
of there ever being any real integrity
in the vote in Florida we will never
have any chance of knowing what the
accurate vote tallies were from this
past election now in the state of
Florida that has been ruled that's off
the table and tonight all we really know
for certain is that the quote newly
counted ballots have drastically
tightened the election and subsequently
triggering statewide recounts all
because of what is gross incompetence
corruption at the Broward County
Supervisor of Elections Board and Brenda
Snipes now she has a history of this
late last week we had a judge ruling the
Brenda Snipes actually violated state
election law now what is even more
outrageous is that this is not new for
Miss naipes now her track record is
literally atrocious why she was even in
this position is beyond any
understanding how she's been allowed to
continue in this powerful position
beyond comprehension last week we
learned that Snipes quote accidentally
mixed in rejected provisional ballots
with several hundred valid votes that
means the entire vote count has been
irreversibly corrupted and just this
past August a judge ruled that Snipes
systematically had mishandled mail and
absentee ballots in 2017 a judge also
ruled she illegally destroyed ballots
following a primary race and in 2016
some Broward County election results
were posted online get this before the
polls had even closed and in 2012 1000
uncounted absentee ballots well they
were mysteriously discovered in Broward
County a week after that election and in
2004 Snipes simply lost track of 6,000
absentee ballots now this is the woman
that could determine the outcome of
these important races for the Senate and
the governor's race in Florida
many Floridians are rightfully calling
for consequences former Governor Jeb
Bush tweeting out there is no question
the Broward County Supervisor of
Elections Brenda Snipes failed to comply
with Florida law on multiple counts
undermining Floridians confidence in our
electoral process supervisor Snipes
should be removed from her office
following the recounts maybe now I don't
think we should wait Senator Marco Rubio
very vocal also about Snipes and her
incompetence and corruption tweeting
quote every vote legally cast and
received within timeframe required by
law should be counted the issue in
Florida has been repeated violations of
election law by the incompetence and the
lack of transparency of Palm Beach
elections Broward County elections and
now Snipes could in fact tonight be
facing criminal charges sources have
confirmed to us on multiple levels
tonight a criminal investigation into
election misconduct in South Florida is
now ongoing just a short time ago
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi
released a letter from the Florida
Department of Law Enforcement stating
that they will work with the Attorney
General Bondi on any criminal
investigation and subsequent prosecution
of Brenda Snipes or anyone else who may
have broken laws and committed voter
fraud now of course the damage has been
done Florida governor turned Senate
elect senator elect Rick Scott is now
sounding the alarm
you don't just magically find ninety
three thousand boats laying around
unless you need smoke for cover that's
why this is so problematic take a look
bill Nelson is clearly a sore loser he
can't stand the fact that he's not going
to be elected for what the first time in
decades and he won't he's just here to
steal this election that's what he's
done that his lawyer came down here and
said I'm here to win the election I'm
not here to give it get a free and fair
election make sure boats are ket are
counted no he wants to win the election
that's his only purpose now make no
mistake when the dust settles here Rick
Scott and Rhonda Santos will take their
rightful place as senator and governor
of Florida but tonight Democratic
operatives they are trying to prevent
all of
that from happening on Friday lawyers
for the Gilliam and Nelson campaigns
they actually objected to a judge to
non-citizens votes being rightfully
denied in other words they want votes
from non-citizens to now count where is
their integrity in all of this tonight
that means they only care about power
nothing else rule of law means nothing
to them and it gets even worse
Nelson just hired in an attorney his
name is Mark Elias his name may sound
familiar to you
he's the left wing hack at the very
center of Hillary Clinton's attempt to
rig the 2016 election with that phony
dossier member Clinton the DNC paid
millions to Elias and his firm Perkins
cuy yeah that firm to dig up the Russian
dirt hire fusion GPS hiring a foreign
national Christopher Steele an ex
foreign spy subsequently put together a
dirty dossier full of Russian lies that
not even Christopher Steele stood by
that campaign opposition research
remember it was distributed across all
of Obama's DOJ by steel as credible
nonpartisan information the contents
leaked to the press before the 2016
election
remember David corns article October
31st 2016 only days before the election
he reported that quote a veteran spy has
given the FBI information alleging a
Russian operative to cultivate Donald
Trump and let's not forget about Michael
is a coughs yahoo reports September 2016
alleging Russian collusion Democrats
were trying to rig the election with the
help of Hillary's bought and paid for
foreign nationals using Russian lies
remember none of it was ever confirmed
most of it's been debunked and as you
can see elias he's a very experienced
democratic operative and of course he's
also been involved in past recounts his
quotes will shock you in 2013 he said
those who have seen past recounts in
Virginia know that they tend to do not
tend to change the results by the way
there was only a hundred and sixty-seven
vote advantage for the guy he's
representing the next year he said quote
rhe council really only happened where
you are talking about dozens or a few
hundred votes separating candidates G
mark I wonder why the change of heart
gun-for-hire say anything just you know
make the rules up as you go along now of
course the Democrats they pretty much
wrote the book on election rigging
during the 2016 election I seem like the
only one that's pointed this out we all
know the Democratic primary we know it
was fixed for Hillary Clinton remember
former interim DNC chair Donna Brazile
admitting this on my radio show remember
she had actually used the word rigged
she kind of tried to back off it in this
interview but she admits she used it
take a listen
what I said in the book was that in
exchange for bailing out the party which
was broke
the Clinton campaign would get control
over certain decisions and aspects of
the DNC that made it difficult if not
impossible for me to do my job it was
unethical but it was not rigged and I
stand by that but you said you actually
used the word rigged of course because I
promised Bernie that I would go
department by Department and do a
forensic test to find out what happened
she used the word rigged herself then
she tells the story how Bernie was
robbed by the DNC machine that Clinton
was controlling the cancer as she called
it hangs up the phone after having to
tell Bernie Sanders the truth said she
cried out of anger over this so we have
one system of justice and elections for
Democrats just like we have one system
of justice for the Clintons and another
one for anyone who opposes them this is
not equal justice under the law or equal
application of our laws now tonight
we're going to bring you updates all
throughout the hour from Florida as they
become available but a criminal
investigation let me repeat is ongoing
as we speak now whatever happens in
Florida there's one thing I know the
Democrats are all excited because they
got control the House of Representatives
by the way the president in retrospect
now that he went out and fought for all
those Senate candidates and Republicans
picked up those seats and that in the
Senate by the way turned the blue wave
into a little baby blue trickle because
now Democrats are doing exactly what I
told you they would do they're now
coming clean the things that weren't
saying on the campaign trail about what
their real plan is to wage what is a
never-ending full-scale investigation
into anything and everything Donald
Trump to destroy this president
according to new reports Pelosi and
company get this they are planning to
launch a subpoena cannon at the Trump
White House firing on all cylinders with
a political hit list of nearly a hundred
targets meaning a hundred investigations
tax returns tour me Janet Daniels
James Comey the impeachment of Justice
Kavanagh shifty ship once to actually
investigates the president's treatment
of CNN The Washington Post Amazon
Democrats they're stopping at nothing to
pursue the unhinge campaign to halt
President Trump and his progress by the
way that means our progress that means
America's progress and of course this is
a plan of endless investigations by the
way very few facts Nancy Pelosi is
actually saying Democrats don't need an
indictment to move forward on their
impeachment fantasies while she and
other Democrats fuel even more baseless
hysteria about Muller's rushar probe
house that look they have been working
overdrive - now smear the acting
Attorney General Matt Whittaker which
was the president's lawful choice period
and don't forget Ron Rosenstein who's
been running this whole thing is
conflicted in multiple ways like signing
the last FISA writing the letter
recommending that Comey get fired but
he's still been running it they didn't
care about his conflicts take a look I
want to make this very clear
if he doesn't recuse himself if he has
any involvement whatsoever in this
Russia probe we are gonna find out
whether he made commitments the
president about the probe whether he is
serving as a back-channel to the
president or his lawyers about the probe
whether he's doing anything to interfere
with the probe mr. Whitacre needs to
understand that he will be called to
answer in any role that he plays will be
exposed to the public we we don't want
there to be any ambiguity
about that you don't have confidence in
him as America's top person an officer
no I don't and I don't have to take it
from me there's bipartisan
editorializing about this that that he
should never have been appointed and
that that it does violence to the
Constitution and the vision of our
founders to appoint such a person in
such a manner to be the chief legal
officer in our country and that's
bipartisan I'll go further the the his
appointment is simply part of an attack
on the investigation by Robert Mahler
the Special Counsel it's part of a
pattern of interference by the president
a part of a pattern of obstruction of
that attentive instruction of that
investigation the only problem is no
one's talking about meddling with the
Muller probe nobody the president has
said twice in the last week no so ask
yourself the House Democrats is there a
single agenda item that they are
advocating that will make your life
better
any one agenda item that's going to
create more jobs make this country safer
build a brighter future for our kids and
our grandkids well we know the answer
tonight is no it's all part of what I've
been telling you they've been hiding
what their agenda is really all about it
slip out occasionally and then they tell
everybody stop which is mobilizing their
political hit lists get revenge they
didn't like the results of the 2016
election by the way they didn't like the
results of this last election they want
to shield their own deep state
corruption and put this country's future
at risk what they ought to be focused on
is our kids and our grandkids and law
and order and equal justice under the
law equal application of our laws and
yes something called our Constitution
yeah the document from which all laws
originated from our founding
Constitution